[Musique]
c'est encore de ballet équestre avec ces
artistes qu'ils soient humains ou
chevaux à l'académie équestre de
versailles
fondée par le chorégraphe bartabas
ladies écuyers et leurs montures forment
un couple uni des années sont
nécessaires pour arriver à ce résultat
la relation entre l'écuyer le cheval
c'est vraiment la base du travail ici
c'est pour ça bien sûr que bartabas
lui-même va essayer de choisir quel
écuyer va monter quel cheval avec des
respects de proportions physique mais
surtout de caractère donc ça s'adapte se
sont tous les matins que les écuyers
passe une heure à faire travailler
chacun de leurs chevaux chaque écuyer en
moyenne 4,5 monture à faire travailler
un travail que les curieux sont invités
à découvrir lors de visites guidées
vous avez le nom du cheval vous avez sa
race et ici vous avez le menu une
plongée dans les coulisses à la
rencontre des stars du spectacle comme
bad les experts en cabrioles ou des
salles d'importance ce que j'appelle
toujours le saint des saints c'est à
dire la sellerie qui est un lieu
extrêmement fermé d'habitude mais qui va
permettre de voir les selles les
harnachements et tout au long de la
visite on va tout simplement voir le
travail on va voir les palefreniers au
travail on va voir les écuyers venant
chercher leur cheval
le prépare en lui parlant on va voir la
nourriture des chevaux également donc
c'est vraiment le quotidien as lattes
imiter l'intimité de l'académie martin
en tête accueillera des groupes de 30
personnes maximum pour partager ses
secrets et anecdotes sur la vie à
l'académie les visites sont proposées
tous les dimanches à 10h30 sur
réservation